what was it like filming stanley's
cameos over the course of your guys's
career and also what does he meant to
you as you know working within we meet a
lot of people in this business and
there's very few people that you lock up
around you know where you get really
nervous and I think a lot of it that
typically happens around people that had
a major impact on you as a child you
know there something about the emotional
memories of things that inspired you and
led you to the point that you are in
your life and obviously comic books were
a massive influence on us creatively and
the mythology behind comic books and and
you know many of the books we read were
you know part Stan's creations and you
know having him on set we were always
like kids you know it is hearing his
voice growing up watching the spider-man
cartoon you know these were things that
were you know really really important to
us creatively so it was always a blast
and he was always a lot of fun to have
on set and you know was a you know
whenever he came on set the crew would
light up you know and part of the fun of
sitting in that writing room eating
donuts and yelling at each other for
eight months about what the best scenes
were was figuring out what Stan's cameo
he was just exuberant the energy that it
would bring the set especially at his
age was was stunning
you could tell he just loved to be there
it lit him up he like Joe said he'd let
everybody else up around him so yeah he
was the kind of guy he always wanted
more lines he always wanted more he
wanted to do more which is fantastic and
yeah he's just you know even even I mean
it was a great lesson that's sort of
even for these small moments you know
he's bringing everything to the table
that he possibly can make the most the
moment I think that it was part of
what's so special with his case
miios was at one of these things where
you would tell him in advance what it
was gonna be or is it sort of like just
come to said Tuesday we're gonna figure
it out no we tell him because sometimes
it took you know would take a little
preparation in terms of costuming you
know so you know that stuff had to be
worked out did he ever say no to a to a
cameo in terms of the character he was
gonna play just that just that one nude
scene we pitched him but it wasn't
comfortable we said okay don't worry
about it
the no I mean he always was game for any
cameo I think his joke onset always was
how come we only get one line
you